Marvel Studios vines for the most
obnoxious logo Oscar and I hate to tell
you this Marvel but you're going to get
beat by bloom house in case you confused
it with Missouri Jupiter holy 1980 Kurt
Russell effects are pretty amazing took
me at least 20 seconds to figure out I
wasn't watching used cars but sin for
making me think I was watching you as
cars Dairy Queen product placement is so
ridiculous and obvious it should be in
Wayne's World
I guess these letters and numbers are
some sort of coordinates but just like
latitude and longitude I don't need also
how in the name of math could this many
planets be clustered up together like
this as if to remind us that Peter quill
is from 1980s earth Peter uses an
electronic football game machine as a
portable radar of some sort two
questions how did Peter take so many
items with him when he got abducted in
1988 and why the fuck would he need to
hack into this electronic football game
to create a radar mmm I can't be mad at
this movie now
welcome cute Groot is this opening dance
but all the mayhem going on around it is
so fun
Emmett you put me in a good mood
guardians of the galaxy 2 but also group
will later prove to be super helpful in
battle even while tiny so this opening
scene just makes him look like a selfish
dick by the way all the characters
fighting this alien survives stuff like
this in the middle of this fight rocket
sees baby Groot almost eat an insect and
decides to tear himself away from the
way more important action to stop him
and how did he even see that bug anyway
me isn't Drax just like a big dude with
no special powers how the does he jump
this high and far also in this hero
purposely gets swallowed by a monster
cliche I'm gonna wonder why don't the
monsters stomach acids kill these people
and what caused this cut on the monsters
impenetrable skin video game designer
also if the aliens skin is tough why
does a sword suddenly slice through him
even with the cut it's not like the skin
underneath the cut is suddenly weak
because the cut exists we could not risk
the lives of our own sovereign citizens
every citizen is born exactly as
designed by the community
she just went from regular dialogue to
expositional nonsense but no warning I
see it within you an unorthodox
genealogy guardians are hired by a race
of people that can read into his lineage
just by looking at him a topic that just
so happens to be extremely important to
the story now that they not lost his ass
at this point even by accident that's
funny we can make Kurt Russell look 29
but we can
make a space confrontation look unlike
Titan II our heroes are now being
attacked by the sovereign who hired them
for that job they just completed all
because Rockets stole something and my
point is that none of this matters this
is all just noise until we get to the
Kurt Russell stuff this could literally
beat any attacking fleet right now it
wouldn't matter it could be the Klingons
and most of us wouldn't even bat an eye
space battle yay I'm not killing anyone
all those ships are remotely piloted
wait a minute didn't they hire the
guardians to kill the space monster we
saw in the opening credits and didn't
the High Priestess say we could not risk
the lives of our own so how would they
have risked the lives of their own
citizens if they use remotely piloted
ships we hired them and they steal from
us that is heresy of the highest order
technically speaking heresy is a belief
or opinion contrary to Orthodox
religious especially Christian doctrine
basic stealing doesn't seem to be
covered here can't you just call it
theft they've been doing a firing with
the intent to miss to make it do that
you'd have to be the greatest pilot in
the universe taking a look at this
asteroid field you'd also need extensive
Battletoads experience find a luck
dragon and watch The Empire Strikes Back
asteroid field sequence more than 50
times for pointers and you'd still die
from this we're about to die and this is
what we're discussing Gamora would be
amazing it cinemasins also how is this
ship configured where two people can
pilot the goddamn thing at the same time
there are still hundreds of ships ready
to shoot down the Milano how come
everybody was crowded around I lack a
minute ago as if he was their last
chance to shoot it down also look at
this great how is the ship not freaking
go exploded literal day of sex machina I
know Gamora as a badass and I have no
question of her skills but there is no
kin waiting she's holding onto the spool
and heavy as Drax while the ship crashes
once again the Starship Enterprise crash
lands through a bunch of trees and oh
you're telling me this isn't the
Starship Enterprise but a ripoff of all
the Starship Enterprise crashes that
have occurred in all 48 movies okay
still a sip Drax comically slams into
trees and doesn't comically die we
almost died because of your arrogance
more like because he stoled annual axe
batteries I can't believe I'm saying
this but I'm 100% with Peter quill on
this one after all these years I've
found you and just in time to save the
day - what are the odds
here's that Biff Tannen from Back to the
Future to join forces with Joker from
The Killing Joke to create a city for
this movie Guardians series continues to
push how
the duck at us without an apology hey
you're out of luck until you've gone
done you're lonely now until you've gone
cow you're stuck here until you've gone
full dear you're a masturbator until you
go Gator hey marvel do you not have
enough characters in these things
Avengers infinity war already has
infinity actors in it it promises to be
the no man's sky a boo bees in 15 years
we buying tickets to save Chris Evans
because he's stuck in a deleted scene
multiverse Ender's Game technology will
be added to the reclining seats at your
local movie theater I mean Jesus I think
it's pretty hilarious that this group
race Club of Ravagers has a super strict
moral code I also find the horns of
freedom to be hilarious but most
hilarious is this obvious foreshadowing
of yondu's death you blew all our hearts
guardians of the godfather' two
sovereigns decide to travel all the way
to a remote planet to propose a deal
with the on do when I'm pretty sure a
king phone call of some sort would do
the trick
do they have phone technology in space
do they have to travel everywhere then
to get to this whole time you thought
yondu was my actual blood relative you
look exactly alike oh man everyone in
this movie would be excellent at cinema
sense somehow against all odds the
former WWE personality has become the
best thing about these movies it's a kid
I used to see all the other kids off
playing catch with their dad in the
first movie Peter quill have mommy
issues and the sequel he's got daddy
issues in the third one it'll be trouble
with the inlaws time basically meet the
parents in space it's my point Peter
what if this man is your Hasselhoff
this asshole shows up and says he's
quills dad quill is immediately
suspicious but the usually guarded and
skeptical Gamora is gonna pull
heartstrings and talk quill into
believing if anything based on the last
movie quill should be stupidly ready for
puppy love with his new daddy and Gamora
should be the one trying to talk some
sceptical sense into him is this spray
thing actually repairing a kingship
magic metal and complex mechanics at
your fingertips
I think if under oath even James Gunn
would admit the scene is only here
because he desperately wanted a slow
motion cool walk sequence and this was
the best place he could find to put it
certainly the TEL rocket what a Dickey
his moment just before this does nothing
to lead into a cool slow-mo walk scene
after 20 plus years quill somehow still
has the David Hasselhoff picture that
was just mentioned one scene ago this
probably isn't as impossible as the
Walkman that still works but it's pretty
darn improbable I can also alter
emotions to some extent yeah like what
like say a screenwriter needs something
to happen in their movie and they run
into a won't they invent my character to
solve the problem which will involve
someone's emotions stuff like that how
in the name of math could all these why
is this movie so obsessed with cramming
up teen heavenly bodies into every space
shot I mean granted these booby traps
end up being useful but exactly how much
ship repair time did rocket waste
setting all that up there was that much
work to do why did I leave only rocket
and baby Groot
if rocket was smart enough to set up
booby traps for the Ravagers why is he
in any position to get seen or shot
during the sequence I put a tracer on
your ship back there during the war over
Zen yeah figures space tech allows for
easy tracers but not tracer detectors we
ain't stupid enough to help kill the
guardians of the galaxy this feels like
something that could have been discussed
a lot earlier if Yan day was so sure his
crew would accept the quarter-million
for the batteries then why didn't you
just say so from the very beginning no
one will be seated during the Yellow
Submarine portion of the movie it was
with Meredith that I first experienced
love I have so many questions about this
3d display that aids egos story like is
this a simulation by a computer
is it egos thoughts either way you slice
it why did the characters look like wax
models I like this better than Holograms
for sure but seems like ego could do
better than this and when I heard of a
man from Earth who held an infinity
stone in his head without dying I knew
you must be the son of the woman I loved
so why did it take until just before
quill got shot down by the sovereign for
you to find it
also ego completely glosses over the
teamwork portion of the first movies
Infinity stones survival scene it takes
a long-ass time for this guy to die in
space and pretty sure everyone from dr.
Neil deGrasse Tyson to Tim Robbins in
mission to Mars would tell you his death
would be near instantaneous I know
mark is an old man without his magic
stick we're talking woodland beasts give
me nebula one on one or even one on five
of these guys but she is surrounded the
hell are they waiting for doesn't she
have a bounty on her head to look if
everything Ellen ego's planet is going
to be plastic and wax looking you might
as well take me to Madame Tussaud tout
just you know the wax museum that I'm
thinking of 42nd Street in Manhattan
next to the AMC Empire and McDonald's
that thing mother told everyone my
father was from the stars it's like that
movie star ma'am it was a John Carpenter
film who worked a ton with Kurt Russell
back in the day but he put Jeff Bridges
in the movie instead
I guess Kurt Russell finally got the
place Norman take your brain in the
center of this planet Peter quill
doesn't respond with what and gets the
stun on the first try
which is a sin but thank God because
this movie still has over an hour left
and just like that movie has given Peter
quill his long sought-after catch with
dad moment it's just instead of a
baseball they're using the soul of a
planet filled the dreams eat your heart
out something I must tell you tomorrow's
opening a door will prevent me from
telling you this very important thing
until it's too late he offered me a
place with the Ravagers said all I
needed to do in like a professional
asshole movie speaks directly to me and
gets it 100% right Groot who previously
was in a cage before the Ravagers
started beating him up and throwing
alcohol on him is allowed to walk around
the ship because everybody got super
drunk I guess and luckily he Charlie
Brown walks to the exact area of the
ship where rocket and yondu are quick
sidenote but why do these Ravagers all
sleep together
also why was no one put on watch this
little dream on the core duty overnight
Groot cuts off some dudes toe without
him feeling it I guess when Ravagers
drink they drink the top she'll blackout
stuff that allows you to lose limbs
without painting he hates heads on
anyone not just himself maybe this is
part of the joke but if rocket can
understand group like this and group can
understand rocket how's he not getting
the message about yondu's fit directors
brother ex machina gotta admit this
yondu arrow scene is pretty awesome
funny and entertaining good stuff
worthless in office baby Groot kicks ass
here despite having gone the entire
movie not kicking any ass why is there
any tension in this goddamn movie Jesus
there's a lightsaber cross with a
Patronus charm meets limbus Bret somehow
yondu miss teaser face during his
whistling spree despite the fact that
he's killed more people than was
originally shown on the ship this piece
of the ship doesn't explode because I
guess the movie told
so you guys should totally die doing
this right it should do way more to you
than comic face distortion right is
Groot man million dancing Christ this
movie runs in place while Peter in the
gang or on the ego planet sure there are
some fun moments here and there but I
just end up remembering the Avengers
going to hawkeye's farm and age of
Ultron
I finally found my family don't you
understand that she should since she's
the one that pushed you to come here
before suddenly doing a 180 prometheus
school of god dammit if she just run
towards the ship she'd have eliminated
about 80% of the bullet danger just Sam
is the ship's aiming computer faulty or
she just really good at running is this
ship seriously running into rocks and
still moving we were just trying to kill
each other but now I'm going to save you
so our characters can reconcile cliche
look we're in a movie that is a little
bit more comedic than usual but I'm
about to give when it comes to how many
things these people survived this isn't
even an attempted humor it's just people
surviving an impossible explosion not
tell me what I want I don't need to tell
you what you wanted skip just once I'd
like to see this asshole change the
batteries in this thing or show what
kind of mr. fusion contraption he has up
in this mug to keep it running brandy
you're a fine girl what a good wife
Jesus Christ can we move the plot now
you played catch with him 25 minutes ago
can we get to the fucking point I don't
know if I've ever been simultaneously
entertained and bored at the same time
in one movie come with me oh she knows
something it makes me worry about stuff
and things the whole Drax finds mantis
disgusting thing was funny the first
couple times now or just wasting more
time why did the movie spend so long
trying to make it seem like Kurt Russell
was the good guy all the stuff with
yondu was more than enough to tell you
that ego was not the father Peter was
looking for at that time I was a Federal
Express man Stan Lee cameo tries to
retroactively Lee justify all Stan Lee
cameos as The Watcher which only makes
all Stan Lee cameos that much more
annoying because you're me I'm lying
this movie could work on so many daddy
issues over this weird celestial
tapestry fathers leave no need to be a
pussy now one of them carried the
celestial genes
until you Peter Allen a thousands of
women he successfully got pregnant Peter
was the only one I might be talking out
of my ass here but wouldn't a celestial
gene be a dominant trait can someone do
a Punnett square and get back to me
you're right we're family
Drax binge watch The Fast and Furious
movies prior to this mission it broke my
heart to put that tumor in ER why hey
would you say this every motherfucking
one of these mother Chris that's mom who
not only dies tragically it drives them
the Winter Soldier killed my mom Martha
why did you say Martha I tried
boobies gag of casting the real
Hasselhoff after all that talk of Peter
loving Hasselhoff just ends up pulling
me out of the movie which was already so
ludicrous is to be skating on thin
suspension of disbelief ice to begin
with
this is the scene knowing Kurt Russell
he just smashed the most priceless
Walkman known to man in the shop the
spaceship has boat steering wheels okay
so how did you find out about the other
kids you know what never mind I think
the real issue here is how lucky Peter
was to have literally thousands of other
kids get kidnapped before him so that
yondu could finally figure out that
those other kids were getting killed
okay before taser face died he sent the
sovereign the coordinates for yondu ship
coordinates that could only send them to
where the explosion happened after that
rocket punched him the coordinates for
the ego planet a planet that took 700
jumps from those original coordinates
sovereign could have put their best
trackers and bluetick coonhound on the
trail and they would have never found
where yondu ship went in literally a
million years you'll be asked how many
sudden ships do we need to show before
it becomes overkill then answered that
question with three times more than you
think this is the problem with the
sovereign still lingering around in this
movie all for some batteries with almost
no explanation of their importance they
bogged down a finale that could have
been pretty simple and turn it into
Jupiter ascending levels of noise and
CGI battles thrilling climactic scene
but why does human Peter quill need a
space masks but raccoon rocket does not
is there air you don't know
Ruby cuts away from this panel because
even it knows how useless it is so later
we find out nobody has any tape to mark
the button group isn't supposed to press
but couldn't a lot of things mark this
button a magic marker a felt pen a magic
marker this is a second time this movie
has tried to ring laughs entertainment
out of showing us characters near the
battle and fudging the actual battle in
the background this will be the second
time the sovereign has one tiny ship
surrounded shoots a million photon
torpedoes at it and somehow fails to
bring it down meanwhile all their ships
get destroyed by a literal ex machina
the only thing missing from this shot is
Scarlett Johansson cocking a gun damn
does yondu's arrow ever suffer from wear
and tear cuz that thing may not up it
says here Jakob is that Ana mantium and
vibranium rocket throws some round
things that cling to egos tentacles and
the tentacles are ready to crush rocket
but then a force field happens because
that's something rocket has all of a
sudden and I have no idea what just
happened you saw it I saw it the moron
nebula crashed headfirst into a rock and
they're gonna live what's that he says
welcome to the frickin guardians of the
galaxy and yet telling him what button
not the press is still a fucking ordeal
okay I seriously can't believe this
movie comes down to a fistfight between
a human and a planet does the movie not
know how a pixel says this also you have
two gods turning into huge rock monsters
and that's the result they crash into
each other and we're back to where we
started for fuck's sake I mean yondu is
mostly redeemed here in the sequel
through sheer screen right but let's be
honest he's still a dick and Peter
barely had any time to bond with him as
anything other than a slave owner also
no I sent word the yonder's old ravage
of buddies told them what he did I don't
know these guys were pretty adamant
about yondu breaking the code do they
really think one sacrifice cleans up its
record and they just believed a rascally
raccoon when he told him a story I can't
believe this movie's over and they
didn't even put tango and cash in a
scene together sweet another contraption
that I should know about that makes
comic book fans scream their genes they
should turn these mid credit and end
credits scenes into a YouTube channel
they clean the fuck up on dangling
exclusive content full of gadgets and
characters that nobody except the most
dedicated fan cares about there are four
credits scenes in this thing five if you
count the discount yondu seen with Craig
LEM they tack on more Stan Lee at the
end - and that's enough Marvel I'm gonna
fight for my movie theater usher see er
you're going down
you got nothing but a billion dollars
and a crazed devoted fanbase what does
that get you what I asked you
[Music]
maybe you just like me when I was on my
ass cuz it made you feel better about
yourself come Wendy let us try to jump
the hilly brush I can't believe I fell
in number the spaceman
gentleman mutation it is the key to our
evolution you people have issues oh of
course I have issues Peter quill left
earth with so much stuff it's a wonder
he didn't think they'd grab some
naturebox snacks of course he was
abducted in 1988 and naturebox didn't
exist yet and even the internet didn't
really exist then the way we know it but
just go with me just keep your mouth
shut
who better to take advantage of
delicious and healthy snacks than a
space cowboy we like star-lord he's
always on the go fighting battles he
needs energy right now if you go to
naturebox.com/tyler first order if you
use the code since that's a hot deal in
brief things are hot hot hot my new
favorite is the cheddar and hatch chili
crackers oh my god not too spicy super
cheesy just enough of both to be out of
this world space they shipped to your
door replace any snack you don't like
and it's all delicious just go to
naturebox.com/tyler Messines and sign up
today for 50% off your first order when
you use the code since that's a good
deal
base so go today don't delay snack away
how about I just go eat some hey I can
make things out of clay and lay by the
bay I just made